last week Kevin I discussed an Oxfam
report that contained a startling
statistic that the world's richest 85
people hold precisely the same wealth as
the three and a half billion poorest
people now if you saw the show you won't
be surprised to hear we got rather large
response if you didn't you'll understand
why I got so much attention in just a
moment let's start with part of our
conversation from last week the combined
wealth that's according to Oxfam of the
world's 85 richest people is equal to
the three and a half billion poorest
people it's fantastic and this is a
great thing because it inspires
everybody gets the motivation to look up
to the 1% and say I want to become one
of those people I'm going to fight hard
to get up to the top this is fantastic
news and of course I applaud it what can
be wrong with this really yes really
somebody living on I celebrate every day
in Africa is getting up in the morning
and saying I'm going to be Bill Gates
that's the motivation everybody's me I
guess chair motivation I just need to
pull up my sock money I don't have sock
okay well let's start with the obvious
because even for you that came off
sounding a little bit rude you do not
think it's fantastic that people are
poor that's not what you meant to say at
all no I don't think part poverty is
fantastic I don't think income disparity
is fantastic what I think is how
successful capitalism has been over the
last 100 years reducing poverty and
reducing income disparity in the last 30
years the number of people living on
this globe in extreme poverty has been
reduced from 42 percent down to 17
percent Amanda I want you to thank
capitalism for that because that's how
it happened yeah I mean I knew where you
were going even as we were having the
conversation you were focused on the
wealthy and why that's a good thing it's
a mistake that people make and I would
say people on a certain part of the
spectrum who feel as though somehow
focusing anywhere else is somehow
anti-capitalist anti-welfare isn't to
say the disparity is growing so the fact
that there are wealthy people the Oxfam
report actually makes a point that
they're concerned there's something
systemic about this it's not that wealth
is bad it's not a zero-sum game but that
the disparity grows larger because the
wealthy are controlling the systems and
that is the problem that we may need to
address you know I'm very concerned when
Oxfam focuses on one country like the
United States I think this is global
probably this was a Global Studies
method so it's global but here's the
concern I have if you want to
incentivize people to create wealth and
start businesses and take capital risk
you can't start telling them that you're
going to somehow overtax them like in
France at now 78% or redistribute their
wealth after they've had success of
actually putting it together my point is
that wealthy people provide taxes at
different tax rates all around the globe
and we've seen tremendous success as a
result of this system most countries
have adopted a capitalistic society and
we've seen from 1900 to today illiteracy
which is the best metric to measure drop
from 70 percent down to 20 this is
capitalism fake it again Amanda saluted
nobody races it is vented capitalism is
good you know far from the truth that I
would say cuz anything wrong with
capitalism it has its flaws but when it
has worked for mankind and there's of
course this period where incomes
actually went up the middle class grew
in America thanks to the New Deal thanks
to capitalism we used wisely nobly of
good policy when it works is when policy
drives it it doesn't drive itself it's
not a it's not a driverless car you
actually need some thought around it and
you might be interested to know that
places like China and the Oxfam report
they talked about China Pakistan Nigeria
fast growing economies where wealth is
booming the middle class is growing the
very thing you're talking about the
disparity is growing there too so it
isn't just a rising tide lifting all
boats it's lifting some at the top more
and the argument they're making is it's
because of systemic issues because the
uber-rich
they don't pay taxes first of all you
know that as well as I do and second of
all they control the political process
and that's where corruption comes in
that's where you start to undermine
democracy and that's bad for you as well
as anybody else the overage will not
fare well as they never have throughout
history when they start to undermine the
systems that got them there in the first
place I can't agree with that at all I'm
not gonna try Anubha rich because the
capitalist society will always
statistically have a 1% that's always
going to be the case but here's the real
blame that I focus on when you think
about what really matters and there's a
very famous 1900 quote it goes something
like this you feed a man a fish and you
take care of him for a day teach him how
to fish you take care of them take care
of them for his life and I think this is
about education I blame governments
around the world because I'm agnostic
I've said too many times and you agree
with me that 1/3 of tax dollars that
come out of wealthy people's pockets are
wasted by governments imagine if that
third went towards education I wanted we
would compress the number of people that
are in poverty dramatic everybody make
it small education is important even the
wealthiest countries in the world like
this one the United States aren't
getting that piece right I do want to
address the redistribution thing as you
go right there every time as though
somehow there's this evil plan to take
more money from the wealthy and the
truth of the matter is Kevin that the
vast majority when we talk about the 1%
paying a disproportionate amount of tax
the 1% means doctors lawyers the upper
middle class the uber rich the people on
this list who may have got billions some
of them pay no tax because of their
taking all of their they're invested in
come as investment income they have ways
to get around the taxation system you
know that as well as I do the same way
corporations get around the tax system
that's the kind of problem that we're
talking about the systemic problem that
keeps capital flowing in a tiny pool
among the rich instead of down to
workers in the form of higher wages or
remember the new business
you are completely discounting the
tremendous valuable socially and
economically they provide by creating
the companies that made them rich
millions of jobs it's all around a world
know what this issue is an oligarch in
Russia he is in West value is the Duke
of Westminster these are not people who
create wealth of course they're creating
wealth they're investing their money in
fact there is vesting their money
because they want to make more money
businesses this isn't madness I want you
to embrace capitalism for all the great
things it's done in the last hundred
years and you can't deny the fact the
world's a better place Thank You
capitalism thank you thank you thank
heart where's my satchel um Evan every
fringe member of the Tea Party the fact
that I see inequity that I can read this
Oxfam report and say there's something
wrong and that we as thoughtful human
beings in democratic nations can
actually work to improve the system
doesn't make me anti-capitalist
anti-market anti rich anti anything it
just means we can do better than we're
doing and to deny that actually just
puts you offside permanently you know
what I hope happens Amanda your son
becomes a great capitalist starts a
business the iceskating rich and I hope
it takes care of giving him a jerk that
takes
they're of you in your old age maybe
you'll help you out a little bit because
he understands the big picture I thought
you were going to take care of me in my
old age not anymore you rapidly it seems
like it's the least you can do you've
learned so much for me admit it now all
right we got to go Kevin have a great
night
take care